treacherous fogs towards deadly icebergs
it might seem that we should have named
it the titanic instead of the human
rights council
if not we need to take an action today
to save the council from sinking
the composition of the human rights
council is as diverse
as the world map
as this assembly is
but this council unlike the assembly has
been established for a specific purpose
to promote and protect human rights
around the world
and we are in a unique situation now
when on the territory of another
sovereign state
a member of the human rights council
commits horrific
human rights violations
and abuses that could be equated to war
crimes and crimes against humanity
butcher and dozens of other ukrainian
cities and villages where thousands of
peaceful residents have been killed
tortured
raped abducted and robbed by the russian
army
serve as an example of how dramatically
far the russian federation has gone
from its initial declarations in the
human rights domain
that is why this case is unique
and today's response is obvious and
self-explanatory
let me
offer you another quote
our topmost priority is to ensure
all human rights and freedoms in their
entirety
including political and civil rights
and decent socioeconomic and
environmental living standards
i believe
that these questions are not an internal
matter of states but rather their
obligations under the u.n
charter the international covenants and
conventions
we want to see this approach become a
universal norm
end of quote
it is hard to believe
that the about quotation
belongs to the president of the russian
federation
another president however
and other times
it was said by president yeltsin in 1992
in this statement in his statement at
the u.n security council
we can only regret that the democratic
aspirations of the peoples of russia in
early 90s
have by putin's regime been
incrementally turned to the opposite
aggression
hatred
and soviet-style thinking and
reflections
including in the area of human rights
and fundamental freedoms
and now we hear completely different
statements here in the united nations
from the russian
federation this week alone we hear from
the russian ambassador that there is a
warfare in ukraine and civilians are
killed in war
it's being said as a matter of fact
this monday
in cold blood and has end up as an
absolute normal course of action also
known as
quote unquote special operation
we agree with the describing of killings
as something normal
the only healthy answer should be no
in order to contribute to the
maintenance of the un's health and the
health of its human rights mechanism
all of you received the russian
diplomatic note yesterday
in which our collective effort to
preserve the credibility of the human
rights council
was considered as an approach to
preserve
the i quote domination and total control
in the world end of vote
and human rights neo-colonial policy in
international affairs
we have heard many times the same
perverted logic of the aggressor
attempting to present himself as a
victim
while in fact doing exactly what it
cries against in
in its note
killing citizens
of neighboring country
trying dominate
if it not colonize it
in reply to that we call on russia
when its rights of membership in the
human rights council are suspended
to return
to responsible behavior by implementing
the decisions of this assembly
and of human rights council
if russia expulses itself from the
council
it would be its own choice
and there will be no need to blame
others
suspension of the rights of membership
of the russian federation in the human
rights council
is not an option
but a duty
and let me quote how this duty is
formulated
in the operative paragraph 8 of
resolution 60 251 and i quote
the general assembly may suspend the
rise of membership in the council of a
member of the council that commits gross
and systematic violations of human
rights end of quote
so ladies and gentlemen it's not an
option it is what the
resolution prescribes
we view voting to suspend the state's
human rights council rights as a rare
and extraordinary action
however russia's actions are beyond the
pale
russia is not only committing human
rights violations
it is shaking the underpinnings of
international peace and security
a draft resolution on the matter under a
slash es11
l4
is a result of the collective effort of
a cross-regional group of two dozen
states that represent all regions
it has been co-sponsored so far by more
than 50 un member states
i call upon all responsible member
states to support the draft
let me now once again refer to the
commemoration
of the one of the darkest pages in
recent history
the 1994 genocide
against the tutsi
in rwanda
on this day of grievances and bearing
its own tragedy of thousands of
ukrainians killed by the russian
invaders ukraine stands together with
rwanda
and calls to reaffirm our pledge to
never forget and to never allow
the recurrence of genocide
which was a result of the international
community's indifference
to those
of you
who for this or another reason opts
today
to keep being a bystander
to abstain
let me quote elie wiesel
addressing president clinton in 1999
talking about the perils of indifference
indifference
elicits no response
indifference is not a response
indifference is not a beginning
it is an
end and therefore
indifference is always the friend of the
enemy
for it benefits the aggressor
never his victim
whose pain is magnified
when he or she
feels forgotten
the political prisoner in his cell
the hungry children
the homeless refugees
not to respond to their plight
not to relieve their solitude by
offering them a spark of hope is to
exile them from human memory
and
in denying their humanity
we betray
our own
end of quote
the genocide in rwanda
was largely due to the indifference
of the world's community
when the u.n did not respond to warnings
in the u.n security council and in
general assembly a year before the
tragedy
that we commemorate exactly on this day
on the 7th of april
today in the case of ukraine it's not
even a year
because the tragedy is unfolding right
now before our eyes
in a couple of minutes
you will have a chance to prove
that you are not an indifferent
bystander
all you need to do
is to press the yes button
and to save the human rights council
and many lives around the world and in
ukraine
on the other hand
pressing no
means pulling a trigger
and means a red dot on the screen
red as the blood
of the innocent lives lost
and this image
of the red bloody dots
on this screen
will stay with you
and all of us
as long as memory
does not fail us
think about it
thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of ukraine
we shall now proceed to consider draft
resolution a
slash
es-11
slash l4
before giving the flow
for explanations of vote before the vote
may i remind the guestions that
explanations of vote are limited to 10
minutes
and should be made by delegations
from their seats
i now
give the flow
to the representative of the russian
federation
[Music]
the draft resolution we're considering
today has uh no relationship to the
actual
human rights situation
on the ground
uh attempt at human rights colonialism
certain part of the member states are
already supported
stated that the possible exclusion of
russian federation female from the human
rights council could be a dangerous
presence
problems and certain countries have not
really been successful not a single
priorities
uh
western
i thank the distinguished representative
of the russian federation
now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of kazakhstan
the chair
kazakhstan closely follows the situation
in ukraine with particular concern and
expresses its condolences to the
families of those who were killed
and wish speedy recovery for those
injured during hostilities
we call on all the parties to speedily
terminate facilities and to search for
compromises aimed at establishing peace
we also adhere to the position that
there is no alternative to a peaceful
solution on the problem based on the
principles of international law and the
u.n charter
humanitarian situation ukraine is dire
and needs constant attention
and kalasana has already provided
ukraine with humanitarian aid sending
three planes with over 50 tons of
medicine and essential goods
regarding the draft resolution on the
suspension of the rights of membership
of the russian federation and the human
rights council
we would like to note the following
first of all in our opinion the adoption
of this resolution will not contribute
to the settlement of the conflict
at the moment it is extremely important
not to undermine the negotiation process
in the current situation
it is necessary for all of us to use
diplomatic efforts at all international
forests including human rights council
in order to find ways to resolve the
problem as soon as possible
secondly
according to the paragraph paragraph
eight of the resolution on the
establishment of human rights council
membership of the council can be
suspended in case of gross and
systematic violation of human rights
to establish that case we need to have
results of a transparent unbiased and
professional investigation
in this regard we believe that the
consideration of today's resolution in
the general assembly must be preceded by
a comprehensive investigation of human
rights violation in ukraine
carried out under the framework of
relevant international mechanisms
we believe that only after receiving
concrete conclusions and reliable
information the general assembly may
consider this issue in the light of the
above mentioned
today we will have to vote against this
draft resolution thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of kazakhstan
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of the bolivarian
bolivarian republic of venezuela
senior president
foreign
foreign
is
creating consequences
is
[Music]
is
is
without the russian federation
in europe
foreign
to vote against the draft resolution
thank you i thank the distinguished
representative of bolivarian republic of
venezuela
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of democratic people's
republic of korea
my delegation expressed concern
to current development of political
situation ukraine
also we are very concerned that
some country continues to push
confrontation and distrust among the
birth states
instead of giving priority to each
tension
and seek political and peaceable
solution to resolve current crisis in
ukraine
we reject a politically motivated
initiative lack of objectivity
impartiality and transparency
the alleged accusation of the
korean
astrology against the civil population
in ukraine including a relevant
reporting image of the civilian death in
butcher
have naturally verified and proved based
on the real fact and object
evidence prior to considering the draft
resolution before us
the independent investigation must be
made
and for this
subsequent time and efforts are required
however
some member states are acting
underbooking very recklessly for their
political goals by submitting such draft
resolution
such political and unilateral actions do
not help to solve the problem at all
we take note of the efforts of the
russian federation to address
humanitarian situations in and around
ukraine
dropped resolution is nothing but
another example of the product of the
political confrontation
aiming at the tarnishing one member
states at the u.n stage
for this reason
my delegation against draft resolutions
contain documents a ces
l4 i think present
i thank the distinguished representative
of democratic people's republic of korea
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of the islamic republic
of iran
the islamic republic of iran has on a
number of occasions expressed its
principal position with regard to the
ongoing conflict in ukraine including
during the adoption
of the two previous resolutions of the
11th emergency special session of the
united nations general assembly
my delegation would like to underline
once again the need for peaceful
settlement of disputes in accordance
with international law and for the full
respect by all parties for the
well-established provisions of the
united nations charter and international
law including international humanitarian
law
we emphasize that sovereignty and
territorial integrity of all states must
be fully respected and the safety and
security of all civilians must be
guaranteed
iran remains deeply concerned about the
continuous deterioration of the
humanitarian situation in and around
ukraine which has a sparked significant
alarm in the international community
we call for an immediate cessation of
facilities and emphasize the importance
of complying with international
humanitarian law by all parties we
repeat our call for unimpeded
humanitarian access to all areas of the
armed conflict in ukraine the
humanitarian needs of the affected
population must be addressed immediately
and the delivery of food medicine and
other essential services to the people
in need must be facilitated
the international community should
encourage and support continued direct
negotiations between russia and ukraine
until peace
is restored the islamic republic
republic of iran once again calls for
the escalation of tensions in the
current conflict and an urgent and
lasting solution to this crisis through
dialogue
mr president we consider the text of the
resolution before the general assembly
contained in document l3 as politically
driven which undermines the impartiality
of our organization
my government attaches great importance
to the promotion and protection of human
rights however we are against the
exploitation of human human dice
machinery for political ends which
contravenes the principles of
universality non-selectivity and
objectivity in addressing human rights
issues
we have always maintained that human
rights should not be undermined by
short-sighted political considerations
here stressed that the work of the human
rights council should be performed in a
non-confrontational and non-politicized
manner and membership in this body
should not be politicized we would like
to reiterate our position on the
centrality of the principles of
objectivity dialogue and cooperation
towards the protection and promotion of
all human dies based on a non-selective
and non-politicized approach we are of
the view that the exploitation of
paragraph 8 of un-general assembly
resolution 60-251
defends confrontation and attenuates
constructive dialogue between countries
for the above mentioned reasons my
delegation will vote against the draft
resolution contained in document l4 i
thank you mr president
i thank
i thank the distinguished representative
of the islamic republic of iran i now
give the flow to the distinguished
representative of the syrian arab
republic
foreign
is
at the same time
is
is
situations of certain
[Music]
is
foreign
we haven't seen
is
is
sources and
is
foreign
i thank the distinguished representative
of the syrian arab republic
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of cuba
facing
[Music]
procedures
uh
a dialogue
in human rights
human rights
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
at least
foreign
is
foreign
is
human rights
is
a
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the
is
[Music]
i thank the distinguished representative
of cuba
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of senegal
this is the rest of the international
community
concerned by the uh
allegations of severe violations
everywhere
and throughout history
of humanity
senegal is in favor of peace in
ukraine
humanitarian consequences
human rights in ukraine thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of senegal
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of south africa
mr president
south africa is deeply concerned about
the continuing conflict in ukraine
the loss of lives
and the deteriorating humanitarian
situation
we reiterate our view
that as a matter of agency there must be
a cessation of hostilities
which would be the first step in a
comprehensive response to the
humanitarian crisis
south africa stresses once again
that dialogue mediation and diplomacy
is the only path to end the current
conflict
wars
and when dialogues begin
and wars and your when there is no
dialogue
in this regard
we welcome the efforts by ukraine and
russia
to hold talks without preconditions
south africa expresses the hope that
both parties will use diplomacy to
de-escalate the situation in ukraine
leading to a durable political and
security situation
we maintain
that all parties have much to gain from
a negotiated outcome
and much to lose from unnecessary and
violent conflict
the general assembly must therefore
encourage mediation and dialogue
and adopt constructive outcomes leading
to that mr president
south africa is deeply concerned at the
reports of civilian casualties in
ukraine
as the international community we cannot
be indifferent to the killing and
suffering of civilians
the humanitarian crisis that has
resulted from the ongoing military
operations
must be addressed and there must be an
urgent opening of humanitarian corridors
and the provision of aid to the civilian
population
which as usual
bears the brand of the suffering when
violent confrontation breaks out
all parties to the conflict must comply
with international human rights and
humanitarian law
including the geneva conventions and
must respect the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of all member
states
in keeping with the u.n charter
mr president
on 4th march 2022
the humanist council adopted a
resolution authorizing the establishment
of an international commission of
inquiry
to investigate all alleged violations
and abuses of human rights and
violations of international law and
related crimes in ukraine
the commission has not yet commenced its
work
and we await its findings on the
allegations of cross violations and
abuses of human rights and violations of
international humanitarian law
south africa is of the firm belief
that the tabling of the resolution that
we will consider today is premature
and prejudges the outcomes of the
commission of inquiry
we must allow the commission
to actually undertake its mandate and
report to the human rights council and
the general assembly on its outcomes
it is also imperative that all parties
to the conflict must allow the
commission to perform its duties without
any hindrance and interference
mr president we recall resolution 6251
which is the basis of the resolution
before us
and which established the human rights
council
also recognizes in the earlier i quote
the importance of ensuring universality
objectivity and non-selectivity in the
consideration of human rights issues
and the elimination of double standards
and politicization close code
unfortunately
the resolution that we are considering
today will further divide and polarize
the matter and the general assembly
itself without following due process
south africa maintains that in
considering the suspension of a member
of the human rights council
we must be consistent and not selective
as this would undermine the credibility
of the general assembly and the human
rights council
for these reasons
south africa will abstain on the
resolution i thank you mr president
i thank
the distinguished representative of
south africa
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of egypt
[Music]
as well as
[Music]
and
repercussions on the organization's
ability to force
its role
in accordance with this chart
and as it has done
75 years
and we believe that such serious
violations
decisively in accordance with the united
nations
thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of egypt
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of brazil
mr president distinguished delegates
we are deeply concerned
about allegations of gross violations of
human rights
and humanitarian law
in ukraine
including
recent reports coming from the region of
buchen
the images of extreme violence against
civilians and the high number of deaths
many of them with signs of torture and
ill-treatment
are profoundly disturbing
our deep sympathy goes to all victims
and their families
the human rights council created last
month a commission of inquiry with a
mandate to establish the facts and
circumstances that may amount to
violations and abuses of human rights
and of humanitarian law
in ukraine
we call on all parties to cooperate with
the commission
so that it can fulfill its mandate
and provide us with an unbiased and
precise information
on the situation on the ground
brazil has decided to abstain in today's
vote
as it believes the commission of inquiry
should be allowed to complete its
independent investigation
so that responsibilities can be
ascertained
only then
would this general assembly be in a
position to better assess and take a
responsible and informed decision on the
status of russia in the council
we must at all costs avoid repeating the
mistakes of the old commission on human
rights
particularly concerning politicization
double standards and selectivity which
had been the main flaw of the previous
human rights system
and the object of well-founded criticism
of its work
the human rights council should be
guided by the imperative of inclusive
dialogue
as the main instrument
for cooperation
sustainable solutions
and peace
mr president
brazil is fully committed to finding
ways
to an immediate cessation of hostilities
and to promoting a real dialogue
conducive to a peaceful and sustainable
solution
ensuring respect for human rights and
humanitarian law
protecting civilians
calling for peace
these are the objectives that should
unite rather than divide us
there is no alternative to a negotiated
solution and to a constructive and
balanced approach aimed at preserving
species of dialogue i thank you mr
president
i thank the distinguished representative
of brazil
i now wish to invite the distinguished
representative
of china
thank you mr president
mr president
um
is
foreign
is
rejected
resolution before
oh
right
all parties
positions
i thank the distinguished representative
of china
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of mexico
senor presidente
mexico
[Music]
is
to
uh
foreign
is
is
facilities foreign
obligations
transparency
foreign
[Music]
or
is
is
which restores peace in ukraine thank
you
i thank the distinguished representative
of mexico
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of chile
thank you mr president
is
consistent with the promotions
that same resolutions
i thank the distinguished representative
of chile
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of belarus
mr president
is
history
uh
which has been expressed over the past
few weeks
in western countries
[Music]
[Music]
which were initiated
thank you for your attention
i thank the distinguished representative
of belarus
we have heard the last speaker in
explanation of vote before the vote
the assembly will now
take a decision
on a drug resolution a
slash e s
11
slash l4 entitled
suspension of the rights of the
membership of the russian federation
in the human rights council
pursuant to resolution 60 251
or 15 march 2006
the general assembly
by a two-thirds majority of members
present and voting
may suspend
the rights of membership in the council
of a member of the council
that commits gross and systematic
systematic violation of human rights
for your information the draft
resolution has closed for e-sponsorship
i now give the flow to the
representative of the secretary
thank you mr president i should like to
announce that since the submission of
the draft resolution and in addition to
the delegations listed on the l document
the following countries have also become
co-sponsors of a stroke es stroke sorry
a stroke es 11 stroke l4 costa rica
guatemala myanmar and san marino if any
other countries wish to co-sponsor a
stroke es11 stroke l4
please signify by pressing the
microphone button now
i see none i think sorry tonga
i thank you mr president
i thank
the representative of the secretariat
a recorded vote has been requested
we shall now begin the voting process
those in favor of draft resolution a
slash
es-11
l4
please signify
those against
abstentions
the general assembly is now voting on
draft resolution a stroke es11 stroke l4
entitled suspension of the rights of
membership of the russian federation in
the human rights council
will all delegations confirm that their
votes are accurately reflected on the
screen
the voting has been completed
please lock the machine
the result of the vote
is as follows
in favor
93
against
24
abstentions
58
draft resolution
a slash es-11
slash l4
is an object
before giving the flow for explanations
of votes after the vote
may i remind delegations that
explanations of vote are limited to 10
minutes
and should be made by delegations from
their seats
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative
of india
thank you mr president
india has abstained on the resolution
adopted in the general assembly today
we do so for reasons of both substance
and process
since the inception of the ukrainian
conflict
india has stood for peace dialogue and
diplomacy
we believe that no solution can be
arrived at by shedding blood
and at the cost of innocent lives
if india has chosen any side
it is a side of peace
and it is for an immediate end to
violence
we continue to remain deeply concerned
at the worsening situation
and reiterate our call for end to all
hostilities
when innocent human lives are at stake
diplomacy must prevail as the only
viable option
recent reports of civilian killings in
busha are deeply disturbing
we have unequivocally condemned these
killings and support the call for an
independent investigation
the impact of the crisis has also been
felt beyond the region with increasing
food and energy costs especially for
many developing countries
it is in our collective interest to work
constructively
both inside the united nations and
outside
towards seeking an early resolution to
the conflict
india has been at the forefront of
protecting human rights
right from the drafting of the universal
declaration of human rights
we firmly believe that all decisions
should be taken fully respecting due
process
as all our democratic polity and
structures enjoin us to do so
this applies to international
organizations as well particularly the
united nations
thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of india
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of timor leste
at the outset i would like to thank you
mr president for reconvening this
session
mr president
the position we took today to vote in
the favor of this resolution before all
of us is a manifestation of our strong
solidarity with the people of ukraine
especially
the victims of this world who have been
forced to shelter
and have fled across the country's
borders as well as those who have lost
their homes their lives their family
members and their own lives our thoughts
and prayers go out
to all of them and their families and
friends
mr president
our world today shows our clear position
to uphold human rights values in all
circumstances and in all cases as the
dark period of our own history has
taught us enough on the high cost of
being victims of war
we call for an effective ceasefire in
ukraine and urge conflict parties to
continue the dialogue and negotiation to
stop this war and avoid further
potentially catastrophic escalation
we commend the efforts of those who have
facilitated the peace talks between
conflict parties
and all for more diplomatic initiatives
to help in finding a peaceful solution
for all
all parties must ensure the safety and
protection of all civilians
it is our hope that peace is reclaimed
immediately and that the important for
work for a healthy
prosperous and sustainable future is
restored
for all
i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of timor-leste
i now give the flu
to the distinguished representative
of qatar
is
made by the united nations and the
international humanitarian organizations
to respond to emergencies
is
foreign
thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of qatar
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of lao
people's democratic republic
mr president
the loud media once again reiterates its
call for peaceful political and
diplomatic solution
to the conflict
and supports all ongoing efforts and
peace negotiations between the parties
concerned
likewise we urge the international
community to refrain
from any action that could feel
escalated escalation of tension
as party tonight
as party to seven of the nine core human
rights treaties
lao pedia
opposes all gross
and systematic violations and abuses of
human rights
we are gravely concerned by the recent
reports and accusations of human rights
and international human rights law
violations and abuses
we of the view that
such serious allegations must not be
taken lightly and must be backed up
by solid evidence
and verified by an independent
investigation mechanism of the united
nations especially the human rights
council independent international
community inquiries
delegation voted against draft
resolution
l4
because we believe that the reports of
violations and abuses of human rights
and violations of international
humanitarian law must be verified by
credible neutral impartial
and independent assessment mechanism
before any action is taken
lao pedia is concerned by the notion
that
any of member states of the u.n human
rights council can be subject to
suspension and other punitive measures
without due process of investigation and
verification
as this issue is of paramount importance
for all united nations member
we all we also believe that all ga
resolutions should be adopted by
consensus reflecting the spirit of
equality solidarity among u.n member
states
in conclusion my delegation believes
there is a dire need for more
clarification
through an independent mechanism that
should be accepted and supported
by all member states before drawing
conclusion and passing judgment
we remain hopeful that the most urgent
task now is to create the environment
conducive
for peaceful resolution to the conflict
and immediate ceasefire agreement
which will eventually lead to
total succession of hostilities
thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of lao people's democratic republic
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of indonesia
thank you mr president
it is distressing to see the hostilities
in ukraine persist
and the number of civilians and
casualties continue to rise
we share the international community's
deep concern regarding the devastating
human rights and humanitarian situation
in ukraine
and we do not take lightly report
reports of gross and systemic violations
and abuse of human rights
including recent reports from bucha
for these reasons we believe the human
rights council must remain seized on the
matter
and supports the secretary general's
call for a thorough and independent
investigation
we also fully support the establishment
of an independent international
commission of inquiry by the human
rights council
mr president
there is no question that those
responsible for violations and abuse of
human rights in ukraine must be held
countable and brought to justice
the commission therefore must receive
full support
and access needed to effectively carry
out its mandate
in the meantime
we have to give a chance for the
commission to work in objective and
transparent manner and present its
findings and reports
we must allow due diligence and not
prejudice and not prejudge the work of
the commission
the general assembly must also be
prudent
it is important to have received all the
facts before taking action
legitimate rights of its members
moreover the general assembly's
execution must not create negative
precedence
that can undermine the credibility of
this august body
it is for these reasons
indonesia abstain on resolution
l4 mr president
indonesia remains steadfast in our
commitment to respect and protect human
rights for all
our priority now must be to save lives
and protect civilians in ukraine
we reaffirm our call to all parties to
stop the hostilities
and to spare no efforts to achieve peace
through dialogue and diplomacy
this is the only way we can end the
suffering and senseless loss of lives in
ukraine and to prevent the increasing
negative impact of the war beyond the
region
so we must stop the war
and i repeat we must stop the war now
otherwise
we will all suffer thank you mr
president
i thank the distinguished representative
of indonesia
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of panama
is
magic
foreign
foreign
is
thank you
i thank that it's the distinguished
representative of panama
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of thailand
mr president
thailand voted to abstain on the
resolution because of the overriding
importance that we attach to a
transparent impartial
and inclusive approach in the
multilateral regime
a decision to suspend the membership of
a member state in any united nations
body cannot be taken lightly
the process must be done through careful
consultations based on principles
verified facts
and taking into account constructive
opinions as well as foreseeable
consequences
we express our deepest condolences to
the people of ukraine and the bereaved
families
who lost their loved ones from the
ongoing war in ukraine
we are deeply concerned with the
escalation of conflicts and humanitarian
crises in ukraine
while believing that prompt action must
be taken in response to all alleged
human rights atrocities against
civilians including in bucha we are of
the view that any action taken should be
impartial transparent and comprehensive
to objectively consider these situations
it would require well-rounded
established facts
and additional concrete evidence proven
by reliable sources
including those presented to
international courts we thus support the
united nations secretary general's call
for an independent investigation to
ensure accountability and hope that the
independent international commission of
inquiry established by the human rights
council would be able to commence its
work soonest to investigate the serious
allegations in an impartial transparent
and comprehensive manner
we strongly urge all parties to fully
comply
with international humanitarian law and
international human rights law and to
protect civilians and civilian objects
as well as ensure unhindered
provision of humanitarian assistance
without discrimination
another life lost is another life too
many on our part thailand continues to
provide humanitarian assistance to
support those suffering
from the conflict in ukraine
in line with the hrc's principles of
non-selectivity and constructive
dialogue we reiterate our strong support
of the continuation of political
dialogues as the only way to end a
humanitarian crisis
is to end the dispute
thus
thailand once again
calls for utmost efforts by all parties
and the international community to cease
and desist the aggravation of fighting
and continue our maximum endeavor on
ending the conflict
thailand reiterates our call for a
continuation of political dialogues
between the parties
between the concerned parties to find
peaceful and sustainable solutions thank
you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of thailand
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of vietnam
mr president
vietnam has maintained a principled and
steadfast position
in support of preserving conflicts by
peaceful means
and with respect for the united nations
charter
international law
including the principles of sovereign
equality respect for independence and
territorial integrity of states and
refrainment from the threat of use of
force
we have followed closely with great
concerns over the situation in ukraine
with severe consequences for the people
it is with extreme concern that we learn
a present reports of great losses great
loss of life among innocent civilians
vietnam opposes and condemns
all forms of attacks against civilians
in violation of international law
international humanitarian law and
international human rights law
recent information
in this regard should be exterming
based on objective and transparent
verification
with the cooperation of parties
concerned
we have time and again reiterated that
it is imperative to immediately cease
the use of force to avoid further
civilian casualties and losses
as well as damages to civilian
infrastructure
the ongoing conflict in ukraine if not
resolved peacefully and experiencedly
will continue to affect the entire world
given the spillover effects now seen
across regions
we are therefore convinced that the only
way forward is to de-escalate tensions
resume dialogue and negotiation through
all channels with a view to achieving
long-term solutions that take into
consideration the interest and concern
of all parties in accordance with
international law
there is no viable alternative
international efforts should be carried
out in a prudent manner in order to be
conducive to reaching a final solution
discussion and decisions undertaken by
international organizations and agencies
should follow their established
procedures and working methods
in this vein we have the view that the
deliberation and decisions
taken by the general assembly should be
based on impartial information broad
consultations with member states
dialogue and negotiations among related
parties is the most feasible way forward
to a peaceful comprehensive solution
it is our hope that the united nations
and member states will work together
toward this end i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of vietnam
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of cambodia
thank you mr president
i'm taking the floor to explain our vote
on the draft resolution on the suspected
suspension of the rise of membership of
the russian federation
in the human rights council after the
world
the spectrum of isolation of a member
state
through the suspension of the tribe in a
human body
will not help resolve the conflict
but only trigger and intensify the
situation
after a fragile
time for peaceful
world peace security and stability
the engagement among the member state
and all relevant joint bodies including
human rights council
is very important
resolving the conflict in ukraine based
on the u.n charter
and the international law through
creating a conducive environment for
diplomatic engagement and negotiation by
the concerned party should be the right
path to be focused
toward ending the tremendous human
suffering
and achieving a sustainable peaceful
solution in ukraine
at this critical youngster we must try
to work in solidarity
to address the conflict in ukraine and
to avoid creating a mis trust deficit
among the membership
building trust and confidence is
absolutely important to deal with the
current situation
with that explanation cambodia voted
abstain on resolution l
4 i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of cambodia
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of uzbekistan
mr president
uzbekistan adheres to a balanced neutral
position on the current situation in
ukraine and hope that the parties will
find
mutually acceptable way to resolve the
situation pursuing solely a political
and diplomatic path
based on the universal recognized
principle and not of international law
at the same time the delegation of
uzbekistan voted against the resolution
on suspension of the rights of
membership of the russian federation the
human rights council
given our strong convictions that any
decision on the op-8 of the ga
resolution 60-251
authorizing
general assembly by two-thirds majority
of the members president voting suspend
the right of membership in the council
of a member of the council that commits
growth and systematic violation of human
rights should debate on the outcome of
surrey investigation of the alleged
violation i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of uzbekistan
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of malaysia
mr president
malaysia remains deeply concerned with
the worsening situation in ukraine and
continues to closely monitor
developments including the humanitarian
situation on the ground
we are greatly disturbed with reports of
alleged human rights abuses and
violations
we firmly believe that those who commit
gross violations of human rights must be
held accountable
we also firmly believe that it is
imperative that such atrocities be
verified
in an impartial transparent and credible
manner
in this regard we support the call by
the secretary general to immediately
commence independent investigations to
guarantee effective accountability
first ministries of the view that the
critical decision
such as the suspension of a member of
the human rights council must not be
made in haste and should not be judged
the outcome of such investigations
a decision of such an important matter
must be coded the same equal treatment
and due processes as in the past in the
full spirit and letter of the resolution
60-251
taking into account all the
aforementioned considerations malaysia
has decided to abstain on the resolution
presented today
mr president
malaysia strongly urges all consent
parties
to immediately take steps to de-escalate
continue to progress towards dialogue
and negotiations to prevent further loss
of lives and devastation
we reiterate the need to respect and
protect civilian life and infrastructure
we also reiterate the call on all
parties to fully comply
with the obligations
under international humanitarian law
and international human rights law i
thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of malaysia
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of singapore
mr president
singapore abstained on the resolution
that has just been adopted
singapore condemns in the strongest
possible terms the russian federation's
invasion of ukraine and continuing
attacks on ukrainian cities civilians
and civilian infrastructure
we reiterate our full support for the
sovereignty political independence and
territorial integrity of ukraine
singapore's position on this has been
clear and consistent from the beginning
of this war
this is why we co-sponsored and voted in
support of resolution es111
resolution es 112
and also co-sponsored human rights
council resolution 49-1
mr president
singapore is gravely concerned and
distressed by the latest reports and
images from bucha and other ukrainian
towns of high civilian casualties and
destruction of civilian infrastructure
we strongly condemn any violations of
human rights and international
humanitarian law
in this regard we urge the full and
urgent implementation
of resolution es 11 1 resolution es 11 2
and human rights council resolution 49
1.
in particular we note the establishment
of an independent international
commission of inquiry to investigate all
alleged violations of abuses of human
rights in ukraine
and await the completion of its work
and its findings
there must be accountability for any
gross and systematic human rights
violations that have taken place in the
war in ukraine
we urge all parties to cooperate with
the commission and allow full and
unhindered access for the commission to
gather evidence and conduct its work
we must spare no effort to protect the
civilian population in ukraine
and to ensure safe and unhindered
humanitarian access to all those in need
we continue to call on the russian
federation to cease its offensive
military operations immediately
to remain engaged in meaningful
negotiations with ukraine and to work
towards a peaceful settlement in
accordance with the un charter and
international law thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of singapore
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative
of brunei darussalam
bismillahirrahmanirrahim mr president
brunei darussalam expresses concern over
the escalation of tension and military
action in ukraine and continues to
closely monitor developments in the
country
brunei darussalam condemns any violation
of sovereignty independence and
territorial integrity of any country and
reiterates the importance of upholding
the principle of a rule-based framework
and respect the international law
brunei darussalam strongly believe that
constructive dialogue and engagement
among all parties concerned is essential
to seek a peaceful solution we further
believe that the suspension of member
states is counterproductive in
addressing any concern any and may
further aggravate the already dire
situation
brunei darussalam reiterates the
importance of diplomacy and further
calls on all parties directly involved
to de-escalate tension and settle all
differences by peaceful means
without resorting to the threat or use
of force in accordance with the un
charter and international law in the
interest of maintaining international
peace and stability i thank you mr
president
i thank the distinguished representative
of brunei
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of kuwait
is
is
foreign
foreign
um
foreign
[Music]
to spare the world and the region from
any serious repercussions thank you i
thank the distinguished representative
of kuwait
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of kyrgyzstan
mr president according to paragraph 8 of
the u.n general assembly resolution
60-251
human rights council the general
assembly may suspend the rights of
membership in the human rights council
of a member of the council that commits
gross and systematic violations of human
rights
this paragraph requires that there
should be confirmed facts of growth and
systematic violations of human rights
our position at the moment is that we
should wait for the results of impartial
investigations into all possible growth
and systematic violations of human
rights in ukraine
including the results of the
investigation of the independent
international commission of inquiry
established by the resolution of the u.n
human rights council number 49 49-1
we are following the situation in
ukraine with great concern
it is especially alarming that fraternal
peoples are involved in this conflict
and human casualties could not be
avoided
we express our grave concern over the
deteriorating humanitarian situation in
ukraine in this regard it is important
to ensure the full protection of
civilians primarily women and children
as well as medical and humanitarian
personnel
what is happening today it is a real
tragedy the occurrence of which
unfortunately was allowed by the entire
world community
kyrgyzstan expresses the opinion that
the text of the draft resolution under
consideration today on the suspension of
membership of the russian federation in
the u.n human rights council is
characterized as politically driven
we are in favor of conducting an
independent investigation examine the
results and facts provided by both sides
mr president
our position is clear
any conflict must be resolved
exclusively by political and diplomatic
means including through the creation of
new formats and mechanisms
i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of kyrgyzstan
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of algeria
thank you mr president
yes
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
um
foreign
oh
foreign
i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of algeria
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of peru
victims
suspended
is
violations
selectivity
uh
[Music]
is
depends
the
um
i thank the distinguished representative
of peru
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of saudi
arabia
peace
foreign
let's
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
is
a
i thank the distinguished representative
of saudi arabia
i now give the fraud to the
distinguished representative of the
united arab emirates
thank you
thank you mr president
the united arab emirates reiterates
again our forceful condemnation of all
violations of international humanitarian
law committed in ukraine
civilians are bearing the brunt of this
conflict and this must end and they must
be spared and parties must comply with
their obligations under international
law
determining the facts on the ground is
important for justice to be rendered to
victims but also in the longer term to
allow communities to heal to reconcile
and to build sustainable peace
as a member of the human rights council
we voted in favor of resolution 49-1
urgently establishing an international
independent commission of inquiry to
investigate all alleged violations and
abuses of human rights and violations of
international humanitarian law in
ukraine
the members of the commission were
appointed on the 30th of march and their
investigations have only just begun
due process demands that investigative
mechanisms be able to conclude their
work
today we decided to abstain on this
resolution because we need to ensure
that any decision we take in this
general assembly is based on due process
in line with resolution 60-251
the united nations is based on the
premise of dialogue and constructive
engagement with each other and even with
those who hold opposing views to us
the organizations that make up our
international system were not
established to be a club for the
like-minded
we need to preserve spaces in the
multilateral arena to talk to each other
and not just at each other and that idea
is in the foundational dna of this
organization
our collective strength lies in our
inclusivity
so now is the time to double down on
diplomatic outreach in order to reach an
immediate cessation of hostilities
throughout ukraine and we support the
ongoing negotiations between ukraine and
russia and offer our full support to all
mediation efforts
now it is time to find a way through
this conflict towards peace thank you mr
president
i thank the distinguished representative
of the united arab emirates
i now give the flow
to the distinguished representative of
kiribati
thank you mr president
and thank you for convening us on this
emergency session
to deliberate
on a drug resolution that's already been
passed
which has the effect of suspending a
member of the human rights council
in line with the provision in a past
general assembly resolution
that allows the general assembly to
suspend the rights of a member
to sit and participate in the human
rights council if such members committed
growth violations of human rights
having listened intently to the
reasoning advance from the two sides of
this issue
kiribati decided to vote in support
of the resolution on the following
grounds
first the images
of hundreds
or thousands of human beings
killed
of innocent human beings killed in
ukraine during the the cause of the past
42 days
is a heart
and soul breaking a nightmare
for all normal
conscientious and peace-loving human
beings
and we do join all peace loving people
of the world in their prayers
and calls
for a speedy ending to the conflict
through friendly
and diplomatic dialogue between the
parties
as a long-standing member of the
commonwealth of nations
we believe it is a wise and civilized
practice
to encourage all its members to be loyal
and faithful
to the codes of conduct of the common
world which requires
all its members to respect
the rules of law good governance and the
rights and freedoms of human persons
and to deter violations of such codes of
conduct through suspension of any
defaulting member and at the same time
allowing time and space
for a suspended member to reform its
conduct
and get back to the agreed code of human
conduct
this practice has worked very well in
the commonwealth for decades
and we believe it can also work well for
the united nations on any member who is
seen by
an overwhelming majority
of members who have seriously digressed
from the codes of conduct
for u.n membership
the suspension of libya and human rights
council in the past show
that it is not entirely wrong to agree
to a suspension decision
at this time
once again we joined the whole humanity
in calling on the party's concern
to put down their arms and to come
together and become part of one happy
happy global human family i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of kiribati
we have heard the last speaker in
explanations of vote after the vote
we now hear statements after the
adoption of the resolution
i now give the flow
to the distinguished representative
of russian federation
is
membership in the human rights council
before
is
is
is
in spite of uh
and stabilizing the human rights sector
on the human rights council and overall
undermine trust in this body
cheers
[Music]
in adopting this decision uh have uh
resorted to open
the end of our blackberry does not mean
that we
are uh not going to claim
the russians
adoption of decisions that meet the
interests of all groups of states thank
you
i thank the distinguished representative
of the russian federation
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of the european union
thank you
mr president uh for convening us under
the emergency special session i have the
privilege to address the general
assembly on behalf of the european union
and its member states
north macedonia montenegro and albania
bosnia herzegovina
iceland and norway as well as ukraine
the republic of moldova georgia andorra
monaco and san marino aligned themselves
with this statement
mr president
the scale and gravity of russia's
violations of international human rights
law and international humanitarian law
as well as the violations of the u.n
charter and the territorial integrity
and sovereignty of another state ukraine
called for strong
united international response
russia is responsible for a horrific
number of casualties
human suffering
and forced displacements russian armed
forces have been relentlessly shelling
cities schools hospitals for well over a
month now
the russian authorities are responsible
for the crimes committed while they have
effective control
of many areas inside ukraine
they are subject to international law of
occupation
the european union supports all measures
to ensure accountability for human
rights violations in violations of
international humanitarian law and
ukraine were russian armed forces
the perpetrators of war crimes and other
serious violations
as well as the responsible government
officials and military leaders will be
held accountable
today this assembly has decided that for
now the russian federation is suspended
from the human rights council
membership in that council is and shall
remain open to all member states of the
united nations
but those members commit to uphold the
highest standards in the promotion and
protection of human rights
russia
has violated those criteria
through its activities in ukraine
the decision to suspend the russian
federation which the eu and its member
states supported today implements the
2006 general assembly resolution
establishing the human rights council
which foresees suspension of members
that commit gross and systematic
violations of human rights
suspension is necessary to uphold the
integrity of the human rights council
the authority of the general assembly
and the credibility of the u n human
rights system
the rare decision this assembly has
taken today sends a strong signal of
accountability
and hopefully will help preventing and
discouraging more violations of human
rights
for the third time in a month the un
general assembly has adopted a
resolution on ukraine by a clear
majority
once again the international community
stands in solidarity with the people of
ukraine and all other people affected by
the war of russian aggression
once again the international community
strongly calls on russia to cease the
destruction of innocent lives across
ukraine and immediately and
unconditionally withdraw
all its troops while the security
council remains unable to take action
because of the russian veto the general
assembly has demonstrated the strength
of international support towards
addressing the russian aggression
against ukraine thank you very much mr
president
i thank distinguished representative of
european union
i now give the flow to the distinguished
representative of the netherlands on
behalf of ben luck's countries
president
i delivered this statement on behalf of
the benelux countries belgium luxembourg
and my own country the netherlands
the benelux countries align themselves
with the statements just made by the
european union
mr president the benelux countries
remain unwavering in their support for
ukraine's independence sovereignty
territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders and
its democratic freedom
we condemn in the strongest terms the
unprovoked war of aggression by the
russian federation against ukraine
mr president it is the third time that
we meet in this emergency special
session in just over a month
today like before
the exceptional circumstances caused by
the war in ukraine leave us no other
choice
we meet because we are horrified by the
reports of atrocities committed by the
russian armed forces in ukraine
by the images from places like buchia
staria bikif mariupo and hostomel that
show a complete disregard for human
rights and the lives of civilians
and by the personal testimonies of rape
and sexual violence that are emerging
clearly these actions are unacceptable
for any un member state but even more so
for a member of the human rights council
it is therefore important that the
general assembly has just voted to take
the exceptional step to suspend the
membership of the russian federation of
the human rights council
it is important because membership of
the council comes with responsibilities
and duties
resolution 60
251 which established the council
clearly states that council members
shall and i quote
uphold the highest standards in the
promotion and protection of human rights
holding a seat in the human rights
council is not a free ride
the benelux countries as recent and
current members of the human rights
councils are strong supporters of its
mandate and we note that members sign up
to a heightened level of public scrutiny
and commit to engage with the council in
a spirit of dialogue cooperation and
self-reflection
grounded in a desire to use their
membership to strengthen the enjoyment
of human rights at home
and abroad
it is clear that with its actions in
ukraine the russian federation is
failing its responsibilities as a member
of the human rights council
but mr president this is not just about
the human rights council what is at
stake is the credibility of the un as a
whole
the u.n secretary general in a statement
to the security council on tuesday
clearly stated that the war in ukraine
is one of the greatest challenges ever
to the international order and the
global peace architecture that was
founded on the united nations charter
that is what is at stake if we allow the
russian federation to commit these
crimes without consequences
in its resolution on march the 2nd the
general assembly
called upon the russian federation to
abide by the principles set forth in the
charter and yet we are confronted with
the opposite
further violations of that same charter
president my final point is on
accountability
i am repeating the call by the u.n
secretary general and the high
commissioner for human rights that all
efforts be made to ensure an independent
and effective investigation into what
happened in bucha and other places
we therefore fully support the work of
the commission of inquiry that was
established by the human rights council
and the essential role of the
international criminal court when it
comes to investigating possible war
crimes crimes against humanity and
genocide
these efforts complement the
investigations undertaken by the
prosecutor general of ukraine which the
eu stands ready to support
so let's be clear the perpetrators of
these crimes are being watched and
evidence is being compiled with a view
to their prosecution
we owe it to the victims and family to
find the truth and to provide justice
and accountability
mr president there is of course a
solution to stop these atrocities the
russian federation chose to start this
war of aggression against ukraine it can
also choose to stop it
to immediately seize hostilities
withdraw its troops and fully respect
international humanitarian and human
rights law i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of the netherlands
i now give the flow to the distinct
representative of lithuania on behalf of
the baltic
countries
there is a point of order requested by
the united kingdom
and i would wish now to give the floor
to the united kingdom
for the point of order
many thanks mr president we're very
sorry to take the full interrupt the
flow of statements but we would like to
seek urgent clarification from the
russian delegation as to what precisely
they just
said in their statement
this general assembly voted just a few
moments ago
to suspend them from the human rights
council and that is now
done
but it seemed to us that they were
suggesting that they were also
withdrawing from the human rights
council which has a different
effect
now setting aside the fact that that
sounds like someone who has just been
fired um sent tendering their
resignation
um may we just ask the russian
delegation to be precise on this point
are they going to be sending a notable
two member states and to the relevant
authorities
indicating their full and formal
withdrawal from the human rights council
for the remainder of their term we think
that has a different effect in terms of
uh the next actions that need to be
taken and their status thank you mr
president
i will now give the floor to the russian
federation if they so wish to clarify
you have the floor
thank you mr president
[Music]
i think we
i thank the distinguished representative
of the russian federation
i note that france is asking flo
for the point of order and i give the
flow to the distinguished representative
of france
[Music]
i thank the distinguished representative
of france for the statement
we have
had the last speaker in the statement
after adoption of this
for this meeting
we shall hear the remaining speakers
this afternoon
at 3 pm in this hall
the meeting is adjourned
so
okay
oh okay
myself
okay
somebody
okay
what
oh
yes
um
is
all right let's read
watch it
thank you
have a good time
um
because
you